[Music]
our first discussion topic today was
euro area economic policies we agreed
five priorities for 2019 in the areas of
growth enhancing structural reforms
fiscal sustainability and public
investment labor markets in Social
Inclusion financial stability and
finally the fifth EMU deepening we have
agreed on a work program that covers all
three strands of issue on the table
meaning first ESM reform then completion
of the banking Union including how to
take for EVs and fiscal issues on this
last point we agreed 12 in depth
discussion at our next meeting on
february 12th on the euro area budgetary
instrument for convergence and
competitiveness from my perspective
obviously it's but it's important to get
the word work going on changing the ESM
treaty we as CSM are the process of
preparing the necessary draft changes of
course we work here closely also the
European Commission and secants the
legal service it's important we do have
a deadline middle of the year
you